all right go on
to see you again
try to get to everyone hopefully i can
all right there we go
i'll do italian again
yeah i mean there's various move orders
you can do last time i talked about c3
d4
d6 this quickly usually knight f6 comes
out first but
okay let's do c3 let's play with the
idea of playing d4
g4
[Music]
i'll write this
let's see
yeah i mean the skills d4 so just
develop
this pin is not usually too big a deal
as long as you keep an eye out for
knight t4
h6
so generally i'm happy to see this trade
so a4 b4 kind of induces it so black
plays a5
at the same time this is kind of bad for
black's pawn structure
so let's take
and we'll get out of this pin and put
some pressure on these pawns
now i have d4 as an idea
but actually i'm also doing with f4
how do i put pressure on black's
position
let's just get the night out of the way
look it up for
some good tactics to learn and bad
tactics to avoid
that's kind of that's a very broad
question to answer
blacks looking at d5 but okay that's
fine
right i mean there's standard tactics
forks pins skewers trap pieces
and so on so you want to do those and
not fall for those
but of course they have books on all the
themes there's lots of puzzles
now i'm pretty happy with this f file
and this bishop's a little uncomfortable
so rook f5 allows knight up knight h4
and doesn't achieve much so let's just
go back to f2
knight e5 yep that's reasonable
actually i don't want to trade this
bishop if i go here i can play d4 and
the knight's a bit low on squares
so normally i wouldn't move the bishop
here but d4 is actually without allowing
this trade
there's something i really like seeing
so d5
but now it's a little slow now i can
play d4 when the knight moves i'll play
e5
with a lot of space
our pawn breaks tactics or strategy
no generally say they're strategic they
might be backed up by tactics
all right pawn breaks are meant to claim
space open up your position activate
your pieces
and there's certain tactics depending on
your opponent's response that means they
either work but they don't
just trade that off this one's kind of
weak and these pawns are very strong
and once again you can see how much i
love these center pawns
now the question is how do i actually i
want to pick up this pawn
and maybe i'll just even go for this
it's a little slow
can also go for the knight all right but
it's 3-0 so let's
let's activate the worst piece
and thanks to these pawns we have this
very nice d6 square
but this would be a sad tactic to fall
for
all right gotta watch the clock one
second
so just load up on f7 it's under
defended
jump in here now we play for meat
there we go all right good game john
right down to the wire